-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when
I catch up with
some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running
a bit behind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running a bit behind today
so if you guys wouldn't mind,
can I write out my weekly
thank-you notes
right now for you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thomas, can I get some thank-you
note-writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, NFL kickers,
for not being called
"football Rockettes."
[ Applause ]
Why not?
Thank you, football playbooks,
for looking like a game
of drunk Tic-Tac-Toe.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, rakes,
for being outdoor brooms
with '90s boy-band hair.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, tennis, for teaching
me that love means nothing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
Wow, dang.
Send that to yourself.
Yeah.
Thank yourself for that one.
It's going to fit in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Is this real?
-It's like a pocket square.
[ Laughter ]
Class. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Imitating bong ]
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's not a bong.
It's a pipe.
-Oh, a pipe. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating pipe ]
[ Exhales ]
[ Imitating bong ]
-That'd be a bong.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Here we go.
Thank you, paper clips,
for being very simple mazes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, the creator of
school buses, for being like,
"I want giant tires,
a bunch of windows,
and absolutely no seat belts."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.
When we come back, we're doing
something fun with John Legend.
Come on back with John Legend,
everybody.